do you know what it is I do okay where
we we like to kind of just hold on to
things for a minute I feel like Oh
everybody just knows everything about
everybody right it's like Tyler Carrie
Underwood's stayed tight-lipped about
the gender of baby number two when she
appeared on The Ellen DeGeneres Show
but the TV host has a hunch about what
she and husband Mike Fisher may be
expecting it's a girl you think it is
okay yeah and when you come back here
and and we talk about it after it's a
little girl we'll say I'll say it was a
girl okay okay yes all right but you did
say it's a whole new ball game which
indicates it could be a boy it's either
a girl or a boy yeah yes yeah well that
I'm pretty good at guessing like I said
so it's I do think it's a girl though I
can see it in your eyes the cry pretty
singer might be hinting at a little girl
with her fashion she wore a pale pink
cape jacket for the appearance and
rocked a blush jacket in her pregnancy
announcement video Mike and Isaiah and I
are absolutely over the moon and excited
to be adding another little fish to our
pond while Kari seems thrilled to be
expanding her family the country crooner
told ET back in 2014 when she was
pregnant with her now three-year-old son
that she and her hubby would love to try
for a girl someday we plan on having a
girl I don't know if you can do that but
at some point we'd really like that
can't wait to meet him
[Music]
[Applause]